[Music]
when the taliban took back control of
afghanistan it sparked panic for people
across the country and many tried to
escape
but those left in the country now live
under a taliban government whether they
like it or not so just how popular are
they in afghanistan and who actually
supports them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the taliban were first in power from
1996 to 2001.
they ruled afghanistan with a strict
interpretation of sharia law
after 9 11 a multinational coalition led
by america invaded the country ousting
them from power
[Music]
during the invasion the taliban were
part of a resistance movement against
the foreign forces occupying afghanistan
the more that night raids drone attacks
and civilian casualties increased the
more it radicalized parts of the
civilian population and drew them to the
taliban
here they claim the french forces killed
women and children
by 2009 more than half of afghans asked
said they had sympathy for the armed
opposition groups including the taliban
this didn't last though and by 2019 that
had significantly dropped
but two years later they were back in
power so how did this happen
the taliban are a predominantly pashtun
group with taliban actually meaning
student and pashtu
and they retain support in the largely
pashtun regions of afghanistan which
make up much of the country south and
east
[Music]
the talibs gained support in the 90s due
to their promises to restore order in
the country they had the same appeal in
2021 vowing to crack down on corruption
in the government
from the very beginning meaning 2001
2002 uh the u.s started to uh to make
payments that ultimately led to that
found played the foundation for the
enormous corruption issues that ensued
over the next 20 years
[Music]
now it's good not bad
but just the woman are not coming
outside the houses
and people some people are worrying
because the
taliban have a bad future before
are you worried
yes
in the first few weeks of taliban power
20 years on we've noticed a lot of
tension on the streets with afghans
unsure about which way it's all going to
go there's a lot of distrust about
whether the taliban really have changed
look at these people
they do not have food at home now they
don't
want me because i'm a girl i don't have
the right to come out of my home without
a meal
huge numbers of women human rights
defenders journalists and former
government staff or those who worked for
the foreigners are in hiding running
from place to place for fear of revenge
attacks from the taliban despite the
taliban's claims of an amnesty
[Music]
it is possible i'll be killed next time
because the taliban don't have mercy on
journalists
and children women on anyone they just
do what they want they only know how to
kill and hit regardless of whether the
public support them or not the taliban
are back in power their claims that
they've changed are at odds with the
persistent reports of targeted killings
beatings and brutal crackdowns on
dissent convincing the world that they
have reformed may be the taliban's
biggest battle